Save now at Whole Foods Market. It's the Summer Splash event, with great everyday prices on 365 brand ground beef for the grill and ice cream for dessert. They have yellow sales signs on ready to cook beef or chicken kebabs too. Level up with savory marinate, spices and rubs, and complete your cookout with a crowd-pleasing cherry pie and their balsamic chicken salad. Available at the prepared foods counter. Get Summer Splash Savings now at Whole Foods Market. Today's episode is sponsored by Love Crunch, a division of Nature's Path brands. Love Crunch is an indulgent organic granola brand that originates from a love story between
现在就去全食超市（Whole Foods Market）省钱吧。夏季清凉活动（Summer Splash event）正在进行中，365品牌碎牛肉和餐后甜点冰淇淋都有超值的日常优惠。准备烹饪的牛肉或鸡肉烤串也有黄色促销标签。用美味的腌料、香料和干擦料提升口感，再配上一份广受欢迎的樱桃派和香醋鸡肉沙拉，让你的户外烧烤更完美。这些都可以在熟食柜台买到。现在就去全食超市享受夏季清凉优惠吧。今天的节目由Nature's Path品牌旗下的Love Crunch赞助。Love Crunch是一个令人沉醉的有机格兰诺拉麦片品牌，源于一段爱情故事，
its two founders, Arjan and Rimjim. In order to celebrate love for Valentine's Day, Love Crunch is exclusively offering listeners of this episode 14% off all Love Crunch products for the entire month of February by using the promo code Love 14. Shop now at naturespath.com slash love dash crunch. If you have ever fallen in love, you probably remember the intensity of the longing and desire that you felt for the object of your affection. The breathless anticipation of seeing each other, wanting the moments together to last,
其创始人阿詹（Arjan）和里姆吉姆（Rimjim）。为了庆祝情人节的爱意，Love Crunch特地为本期节目的听众提供优惠，在整个二月期间，使用促销代码Love 14购买所有Love Crunch产品均可享受86折优惠。现在就访问naturespath.com/love-crunch选购吧。如果你曾经坠入爱河，你可能还记得那种对爱慕对象所感受到的强烈渴望和向往。那种见到对方时呼吸急促的期待，那种希望在一起的时刻能够持续，
forever. For most of us, that passionate intensity fades over time. Few people celebrate their 10th or 20th Valentine's Day together with the same enthusiasm that they did their first. But some couples remain deeply and passionately in love even after decades of marriage. What is it that sets those relationships apart? What makes love like that last? Are some couples just lucky? Or are there things that any couple can do to sustain love or rekindle it in a long-term relationship? What does science say about the secrets of everlasting love? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast.
永远。对我们大多数人来说，那种炽热的激情会随着时间的推移而消退。很少有人能像第一次那样，怀着同样的热情庆祝他们在一起的第10个或第20个情人节。但有些夫妻即使在结婚几十年后，依然深爱着对方，充满激情。是什么让这些关系与众不同？是什么让那样的爱情能够持久？有些夫妻只是运气好吗？还是说任何夫妻都可以做些什么来维持爱情，或在长期关系中重燃爱火？科学对永恒爱情的秘密有什么说法？欢迎收听《心理学对话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是
of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Arthur Aaron, a professor of psychology at Stony Brook University in New York. Dr. Aaron has spent decades studying how people develop and maintain close relationships, particularly romantic relationships. He developed the self-expansion model of relationships, which posits that one main motivation for forming bonds with others is our own personal growth. Relationships allow us to grow and expand our sense of self. Outside of academia, Dr. Aaron is perhaps best known for developing the 36 questions that lead to love, work that was profiled in a New York Times modern love column that went viral a few years ago. Thank you for
美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我们今天的嘉宾是纽约石溪大学（Stony Brook University）的心理学教授阿瑟·亚伦（Dr. Arthur Aaron）博士。亚伦博士花了数十年时间研究人们如何发展和维持亲密关系，特别是浪漫关系。他提出了关系的“自我扩展模型”（self-expansion model），该模型认为，与他人建立联系的一个主要动机是我们自身的个人成长。关系让我们能够成长并扩展我们的自我意识。在学术界之外，亚伦博士最出名的或许是开发了“通往爱情的36个问题”，这项工作曾被《纽约时报》的“现代爱情”专栏报道，并在几年前走红网络。感谢您
joining us, Dr. Aaron. My pleasure to be here. Let's start with the big question I posed in the introduction. What makes love last? You've done research on couples who say they're still madly in love after many years together. How do they do it? Let me just say a word about the fact it really can happen. We have a lot of studies showing that. People find it hard to believe it really can happen. For example, in a representative U.S. survey we did a few years ago, of people married 10 years or longer, 40% claimed to be very intensely in love. And that was on a seven-point scale where five was somewhat in love, six is a little in love, you know, those are the low end, but intensely in love, very in love,
加入我们，亚伦博士。很高兴来到这里。让我们从我在介绍中提出的那个大问题开始。是什么让爱情持久？您对那些结婚多年后仍深爱着对方的夫妻进行了研究。他们是怎么做到的？我先说一句，这种情况确实可能发生。我们有很多研究证明了这一点。人们觉得这很难相信。例如，我们在几年前对美国结婚10年或以上的夫妻进行了一项代表性调查，40%的人声称自己依然深爱着对方。这是在一个七分量表上，5分是“有点爱”，6分是“有一点爱”，你知道，这些是低端，但“深爱着”、“非常爱”，
this is even higher than that, very intensely in love. And if you look at people who were married greater than 30 years, we still had almost that many. 40% of women, 35% of men. Now, of course, that's the people who are still together. So it means if you get married and only half are still together 10 years later, 20% is. But still, that's a lot of people. And we were, concerned whether this is really the case or they're just saying so. And so we did some fMRI studies, some brain scan studies. Now, I've done with my colleagues a lot of studies that people who are newly in love. So we know what the brain looks like, particularly something called the dopamine reward area responds when you see a fallen in love. So we recruited people who claimed to be,
这比那个还要高，是非常深爱。如果你看那些结婚超过30年的人，我们发现比例几乎一样。40%的女性，35%的男性。当然，这是指那些仍然在一起的人。所以这意味着如果你结婚了，只有一半人在10年后还在一起，那么比例就是20%。但即便如此，那也是很多人。我们当时担心这是否真的是事实，还是他们只是随口说说。所以我们做了一些功能性磁共振成像（fMRI）研究，也就是脑部扫描研究。我和我的同事做过很多关于刚坠入爱河的人的研究。所以我们知道大脑是什么样子的，特别是当你看到坠入爱河的人时，大脑中所谓的“多巴胺奖励区”会有反应。所以我们招募了那些声称自己，
we went around in New York and we recruited people who said they're, whether they were still madly in love with their partner, who were married at least 10 years. On the average, the sample we studied was married 20 years. And they were really, they claimed to be intensely in love. We interviewed them. They looked like it. My then-graduate student, now a very successful professor, researcher, Bianca Acevedo, told me about one couple she interviewed and she could see it. They were saying, you know, when we talk to our friends, these are people who are in their 60s, when we talk to our friends, they're always complaining because we're always all over each other physically. So when we looked at their brains, when we did the same basic brain scan, what happens when you see your partner versus familiar other equally attractive? What we see is that same activation, as much as the people who've newly fallen in love.
我们在纽约四处招募了那些声称自己结婚至少10年，但仍然疯狂爱着伴侣的人。平均而言，我们研究的样本结婚了20年。他们确实声称自己深爱着对方。我们采访了他们。他们看起来确实如此。我当时的研究生，现在是一位非常成功的教授和研究员，比安卡·阿塞韦多（Bianca Acevedo），告诉我她采访过的一对夫妻，她能看出来。他们说，你知道，当我们和朋友交谈时——这些人已经60多岁了——当我们和朋友交谈时，他们总是抱怨，因为我们总是身体上黏在一起。所以当我们观察他们的大脑时，当我们做同样的脑部扫描，观察当你看到伴侣与看到同样有吸引力的熟悉他人时的反应，我们看到的是同样的激活，和那些刚坠入爱河的人一样多。
There were some minor differences. They didn't show the anxiety that we see in people who have just. fallen in love, and they did show activation in what's called a pair bonding area, which we see in animals. But it does seem like it really can happen. Now, not everyone's happy to hear this, because if you're planning to get married, it sounds good. But one of the ways people feel good about their relationships is by comparing to other relationships. But on the other hand, it should be a motivation to do something. Are there characteristics that these madly in love couples tend to share? Do they meet at older or younger ages? Does that matter? Do they have
有一些细微的差别。他们没有表现出我们在刚坠入爱河的人身上看到的焦虑，而且他们在所谓的“配对结合区”表现出了激活，我们在动物身上也看到了这一点。但这看起来确实是可能发生的。现在，并不是每个人都乐于听到这个消息，因为如果你正打算结婚，这听起来不错。但人们对自己的关系感到满意的方式之一，就是通过与其他关系进行比较。但另一方面，这应该成为做点什么的动力。这些深爱着的夫妻有什么共同的特征吗？他们是在较年长还是较年轻时相遇的？这有关系吗？他们有
certain types of personalities? Are they very similar in their outlooks on life? Or are they opposites who attracted? Well, as far as initial attraction, that doesn't seem to affect things as much years later. Now, who you are and who your partner is do matter a lot and your skills matter a lot. And, you know, people think similarity is very important. And it turns out it's, I mean, it's important to share values, but it's not so important to share personality. You know, if one of you gets angry easy, it's not better if both of you get angry easily.
某种类型的人格吗？他们对生活的看法非常相似吗？还是说异性相吸？嗯，就最初的吸引力而言，多年后这似乎并没有太大影响。现在，你是谁以及你的伴侣是谁确实很重要，你的技能也非常重要。而且，你知道，人们认为相似性非常重要。事实证明，我的意思是，分享价值观很重要，但分享人格并不那么重要。你知道，如果你们中有一个人容易生气，如果两个人都容易生气，情况并不会更好。
But we like to think we're similar on all sorts of things. And, of course, as people are longer together, they become more similar, not just in their ideas, but in their physical appearance. People tend to look more alike over time. Anyway, I won't go into that side step. You can measure that? I mean, it's for real.
但我们喜欢认为我们在各方面都很相似。当然，随着人们在一起的时间越长，他们变得越相似，不仅是在想法上，在身体外貌上也是如此。人们随着时间的推移往往看起来越来越像。总之，我不去谈那个题外话了。你能测量那个吗？我是说，那是真的吗？
People always say that. Oh yeah, there's been some wonderful studies done where they've shown people pictures of individuals taken when they were getting married. And then they showed people pictures of who they are now. And they had, you know, many different people they showed them. The people right away saw much more similarity. So what can people do to make this happen? And we know quite a bit. We don't know everything.
人们总是这么说。哦，是的，有一些很棒的研究，他们向人们展示了个人结婚时拍的照片。然后他们向人们展示了他们现在的照片。他们让很多人看了这些照片。人们立刻就看到了更多的相似之处。那么人们能做些什么来让这种情况发生呢？我们知道得相当多。我们并不是什么都知道，
but we know quite a bit. And you can help make it happen. There are certain things that are sort of essential to make it basically okay. And those are crucial because if it's not basically okay, it's hard to sparkle. And there are people who are intensely in love that aren't happy, but not many. Usually, if your partner is responding and you're, you know, intensely in love, you're very happy. So there are basically four basic things that are sort of crucial to make a relationship. at least okay. I mean, sometimes they'll manage without them, but they really make a difference.
但我们知道得相当多。你可以帮助实现这一点。有些事情是让关系基本保持良好的必要条件。这些至关重要，因为如果基础不稳，就很难产生火花。有些人深爱着对方却并不快乐，但不多。通常，如果你的伴侣有回应，而你又深爱着对方，你会非常快乐。所以，让一段关系至少保持良好，有四个基本要素。我的意思是，有时没有它们也能维持，但它们确实能带来不同。
One of the biggest is another one people don't want to hear, and that is yourself. If you're anxious or depressed or insecure, it's very hard to feel happy in your relationship. Initially, you might be, but then you sort of start blaming it on the other person or, you know, you just go back to being unhappy. So one of the biggest things you can do is to get therapy, or if it's not very big, learn to meditate, or if it's very big, you know, see a psychiatrist, get medication. You know, if you're insecure, that's another big factor. There are some things you can do. People with low self-esteem have a hard time. Some great work by Marie and Holmes and others. If you have low self-esteem, it's hard to feel, you know, your partner likes you. There's a whole
其中最大的一点是另一点人们不想听到的，那就是你自己。如果你焦虑、抑郁或缺乏安全感，很难在关系中感到快乐。起初你可能会，但后来你开始把原因归咎于对方，或者，你知道，你又回到了不快乐的状态。所以你能做的最重要的事情之一就是接受治疗，或者如果问题不是很大，学习冥想；如果问题很大，你知道，去看精神科医生，进行药物治疗。你知道，如果你缺乏安全感，那是另一个重要因素。你可以做一些事情。自尊心低的人很难受。玛丽·霍姆斯（Marie Holmes）和其他人做了一些很棒的研究。如果你自尊心低，很难感觉到，你知道，你的伴侣喜欢你。有一个
joke of Groucho Marx. I wouldn't belong to any club that would have me as a member. So, you know, you wonder, you know, if your partner, what's wrong with your partner if they like you? Or could your partner really like you? So some nice research has been done showing that one of the things you can do is to think if your partner complements you, you know, try to think about it abstractly. Try to look at sort of why your partner said it and what it means to you. Of course, who your partner is matters too, but matters even more who you are. And then another one, A huge one is stress. If you're under great stress or some big thing happens in your life, you know, one of you
格劳乔·马克思（Groucho Marx）的笑话。我不会加入任何会接纳我为成员的俱乐部。所以，你知道，你会怀疑，如果你的伴侣喜欢你，你的伴侣是不是有什么问题？或者你的伴侣真的能喜欢你吗？所以一些不错的研究表明，你可以做的一件事是，如果你的伴侣称赞你，你知道，试着抽象地思考它。试着去想为什么你的伴侣会这么说，以及这对你意味着什么。当然，你的伴侣是谁也很重要，但你是谁更重要。然后另一个，一个巨大的因素是压力。如果你承受着巨大的压力，或者生活中发生了什么大事，你知道，你们中有一个人
loses a job or worse yet, a child dies, you know, those are really hard. And they're not only hard because they affect you. When you're under stress, you don't behave as well. And you're likely to, you know, if your partner does one little thing, you may just go off the top. You know, you can't see, oh, well, they weren't usually like that. And if your partner does it, it's hard to remember that, you know, they're under stress, if they're also under stress.
失业了，或者更糟的是，孩子去世了，你知道，这些真的很难。它们不仅因为影响你而变得困难。当你承受压力时，你的表现就不会那么好。你很可能会，你知道，如果你的伴侣做了一件小事，你可能会直接爆发。你知道，你看不见，哦，好吧，他们通常不是那样的。如果你的伴侣做了这件事，很难记住，你知道，如果他们也承受着压力，他们也是在压力之下。
So it's important when you're under stress to try to remember this effect that stress can have because your ability to think broadly is hard. But if you can remember that one thing, it can help in interpreting yourself and your partner's behavior. And more generally, communication skills is a huge factor. Your partner and you need to feel you're hearing each other. That it's called responsiveness. Harry Reese, great social psychologist in this field, he and many of his colleagues have shown that one of the biggest things in interacting with people, especially close others, is feeling that they're responsive to you.
所以当你承受压力时，试着记住压力可能产生的这种影响很重要，因为你全面思考的能力会变差。但如果你能记住那一点，它有助于解读你自己和伴侣的行为。更广泛地说，沟通技巧是一个巨大的因素。你的伴侣和你需要感觉到你们在倾听对方。这被称为“回应性”（responsiveness）。哈里·里斯（Harry Reese），这个领域伟大的社会心理学家，他和他的许多同事已经证明，在与人互动时，尤其是与亲近的人互动时，最重要的事情之一就是感觉到他们对你有回应。
They hear you, they understand you. They, you know, they verify what you say. They care about you. And so you want to show that to your partner and you want to reveal things about yourself. We'll talk more about the 36th questions later, but that's a little what that's about. You want to reveal a little to give the other opportunity to be responsive. And you want to be responsive to your partner. And then, of course, there's handling conflict, which is a huge problem.
他们听到了你，他们理解你。他们，你知道，他们验证了你说的话。他们关心你。所以你想向你的伴侣展示这一点，你也想透露关于你自己的事情。我们稍后会谈论那36个问题，但这正是它的意义所在。你想透露一点，给对方提供回应的机会。而且你想对你的伴侣有回应。然后，当然，还有处理冲突，这是一个巨大的问题。
I was going to ask that one. That's a big one, yeah. Yeah. Conflict's kind of inevitable in relationships, but it isn't always rising. But one of the recent lines of research on that has shown that when you're in a conflict, try to think about it from a third person's perspective who is neutral. but they care about your relationship, but they're not on either side. Try to see if you can reflect it from that perspective.
我正要问那个。那是个大问题，是的。是的。冲突在关系中是不可避免的。但它并不总是会升级。但最近关于这一点的一系列研究表明，当你处于冲突中时，试着从一个中立的第三方的角度去思考。他们关心你们的关系，但他们不偏袒任何一方。试着看看你是否能从那个角度去反思。
And then there's some sort of rules you should follow. John Gottman's done all this wonderful research. He calls them the Four Horsemen of the Apocalypse. Right, right. Things you should avoid, you know, criticism, defensiveness, contempt, stonewalling, you know, what he calls kitchen sinking. You know, the person does one thing, and you remind them of everything that's always annoyed you. You don't want to do that.
然后有一些你应该遵循的规则。约翰·戈特曼（John Gottman）做了所有这些精彩的研究。他称之为“末日四骑士”。对，对。你应该避免的事情，你知道，批评、防御、蔑视、筑墙（stonewalling），你知道，他所谓的“翻旧账”（kitchen sinking）。你知道，对方做了一件事，你就提醒他们所有一直让你恼火的事情。你不想那样做。
In fact, you should sort of sometimes discuss. this with your partner when you're not in a conflict so that you have some sort of rules. And another thing is, if you're really worked up, I mean, in a negative way, you're angry or upset, it's not so good to discuss it. You know, if your pulse is over 100, the thing to do is to go, you know, say to your partner, I'm not leaving you, I'm not, you know, just stopping talking about it, but I should have 20 minutes to settle down. Right, right.
事实上，你应该在不发生冲突的时候和你的伴侣讨论这些规则。还有一件事是，如果你真的情绪激动，我的意思是，以一种消极的方式，你很生气或心烦意乱，讨论它并不是很好。你知道，如果你的脉搏超过100，该做的是，去，你知道，对你的伴侣说，我不是要离开你，我不是，你知道，只是停止谈论它，但我需要20分钟冷静下来。对，对。
And then you go back to the discussion. You don't want to just leave it. Anyway, those are some things for handling conflict that we know. It's not my main area of expertise, but it's really important. And then there's one other thing, and that is family and friends, if they disapprove. The iconic example of love in the West is what? The iconic example of love. In literature in the West.
然后你再回到讨论中。你不想就这样搁置它。总之，这些是我们知道的处理冲突的一些方法。这不是我的主要专业领域，但它真的很重要。然后还有一件事，那就是如果家人和朋友不赞成。西方爱情的标志性例子是什么？爱情的标志性例子。在西方文学中。
Well, I mean, you know, there's always Romeo and Juliet, and of course there was family conflict. Yeah, how did that work out? Not so well. Yeah, they were intensely in love. But no, if your family, this isn't as big a problem for most Westerners, but in many cultures and many people who are from other cultures, what your family thinks matters a lot. In the short run, sometimes it makes you feel better if your parents disapprove if you're an American. But in the long run, it's hard, especially once you start having children and stuff like that.
嗯，我的意思是，你知道，总有《罗密欧与朱丽叶》，当然还有家庭冲突。是的，结果如何？不太好。是的，他们深爱着对方。但不是，如果你的家人——这对大多数西方人来说不是什么大问题，但在许多文化中，以及许多来自其他文化的人来说，你的家人怎么想非常重要。在短期内，如果你是美国人，父母不赞成有时会让你感觉更好。但从长远来看，这很难，尤其是当你开始有孩子之类的事情之后。
So you really want to work. And, of course, if your friends strongly disapprove, you really want to work to create good relationships. So those are some things that are sort of essential. I mean, essential is a little too strong because there are people who somehow manage, you know, if just one of these things is in place if the other three are out. But it's a lot harder. And so these are things you want to do to get it to the level where, you know, it's at least okay. Did you know that Love Crunch was originally created by Arjan and Rimjim as a treat for their
所以你真的想努力。当然，如果你的朋友强烈反对，你真的想努力去建立良好的关系。所以这些是某种程度上必不可少的事情。我的意思是，“必不可少”有点太强了，因为有些人不知何故设法维持了，你知道，如果这四件事中只有一件到位，而其他三件缺失。但这要困难得多。所以这些是你想要做的事情，让关系达到至少还可以的水平。你知道Love Crunch最初是阿詹和里姆吉姆为他们的
wedding guests? The wedding couple asked their guests to donate or volunteer to a charity of their choice, rather than purchase a wedding gift. That's why love and giving back are in the very DNA of Love Crunch. They are proud to announce that they've doubled their annual donation goal to a minimum of $2 million worth of food through the Bight for Bite for Bite Program and supports organizations like the Trevor Project,
婚礼宾客准备的款待吗？这对新人要求宾客向他们选择的慈善机构捐款或志愿服务，而不是购买结婚礼物。这就是为什么爱和回馈是Love Crunch基因的一部分。他们很自豪地宣布，他们已经将年度捐赠目标翻了一番，通过“Bite for Bite”计划捐赠至少价值200万美元的食物，并支持像“特雷弗项目”（Trevor Project）这样的组织，
which is the world's largest suicide prevention and crisis intervention organization for LGBTQ young people. Love Crunch uses only certified Italian fair trade dark chocolate so that local farmers and producers throughout the world are compensated fairly. Help us spread the love this February by shopping Love Crunch and get 14% off all Love Crunch products for the entire month of February by using the promo code, Love 14. Shop now at naturespath.com slash love dash crunch. So what advice would you give to our listeners who, you know, I feel inspired by what you're saying
这是全球最大的LGBTQ青少年自杀预防和危机干预组织。Love Crunch只使用经过认证的意大利公平贸易黑巧克力，以确保全球各地的当地农民和生产者得到公平的报酬。请在二月通过购买Love Crunch来帮助我们传播爱，并在整个二月期间使用促销代码“Love 14”购买所有Love Crunch产品，即可享受86折优惠。现在就访问naturespath.com/love-crunch选购吧。那么，你会给我们的听众什么建议呢，你知道，我感到被你所说的所鼓舞，
and they want to improve their relationships. So what can they do to take a relationship that's maybe okay or maybe it's gotten a little boring? How can they rekindle the intense love that they felt at the beginning? Well, there's a few crucial things. One is, of course, creating time together by yourself, particularly if you have kids, you know, or you're living with an extended family. You need to have some time by yourself with your partner, I mean. You know, you need to have some time together.
他们想改善他们的关系。那么他们可以做些什么来让一段可能还可以，或者可能变得有点无聊的关系变得更好呢？他们如何重燃起初感受到的那种强烈的爱？嗯，有几件关键的事情。一是，当然，创造你们单独在一起的时间，特别是如果你有孩子，你知道，或者你和大家庭住在一起。你需要有一些和你伴侣单独在一起的时间，我是说。你知道，你们需要有一些在一起的时间。
Of course, right now during the pandemic, you mean you did a little time apart, too. A little too much time, yeah. Yeah. But the thing is to sort of pull yourself out of this environment and just working and this and that and really have some time to get. And then how you use that time is kind of crucial. You know, being playful is really, you know, really important. And particularly my research on self-expansion is really central, doing things that are new and interesting with your partner matters hugely.
当然，现在在疫情期间，你的意思是你们也有一点分开的时间。太多了一点，是的。是的。但关键是要把自己从这种环境中拉出来，不仅仅是工作，这个那个，真正有一些时间在一起。然后你如何利用这段时间至关重要。你知道，保持爱玩的心态真的，你知道，非常重要。特别是我的关于“自我扩展”的研究非常核心，和你的伴侣一起做一些新的、有趣的事情非常重要。
You know, not just same old, same old, but new, different. So what might those things be if you're talking about self-expansion? Well, it could be, you know, at one level it could be flying, you know, in a helicopter together, but it could also just be taking a cooking class together or, you know, doing something new and interesting. And it could be a little thing or a big thing. My wife and I, you know, we went kayaking, you know, down the river. And that was lovely on our own.
你知道，不仅仅是老一套，而是新的、不同的。那么如果谈到自我扩展，那些事情可能是什么呢？嗯，它可以是，你知道，在一个层面上，它可以是一起坐直升机飞行，但也可以只是去上一门烹饪课，或者，你知道，做一些新的、有趣的事情。它可以是一件小事，也可以是一件大事。我和我妻子，你知道，我们去划皮划艇，你知道，顺流而下。那在我们自己看来很可爱。
It wasn't dangerous. We picked a river that wasn't dangerous, just the fun of it. It's a little challenging, but that makes it all the better. Another example is one night we were coming home or coming back from a play. And we walked by a bar and he said, we haven't hung out in a bar in years and years. So we went hung out in a bar for a little while. So, you know, in one of our studies, one of our first studies, we had a, large sample of couples agreed to be in the study, and we asked them, we gave them a big list
它并不危险。我们选了一条不危险的河流，只是为了好玩。它有一点挑战性，但这让它变得更好。另一个例子是有一天晚上我们回家，或者从看戏回来。我们路过一家酒吧，他说，我们已经好多年没在酒吧里待过了。所以我们去酒吧待了一会儿。所以，你知道，在我们的一项研究中，我们最初的研究之一，我们有一大群夫妻同意参加这项研究，我们问他们，我们给了他们一大份
of activities couples do together. And we said, you know, for each one separately, we said, how exciting would this be to do with your partner and how pleasant would it be? And then we gave them a list that was based on what both of them, it's highly pleasant, but only moderately exciting. And another half were randomly assigned to get a list that was highly excited. but not rated as high unpleasantness, not low unpleasantness. And we asked them to do something for about an hour every week from the list we gave them. And then after 10 weeks, the couples that had done from the exciting list were substantially increased in their satisfaction with their relationship.
夫妻一起做的活动清单。我们说，你知道，对每一项分别问，和你的伴侣做这件事会有多兴奋，会有多愉快？然后我们给他们一份清单，基于他们两个都认为非常愉快，但只有中等兴奋度的活动。另一半被随机分配到一份被评为非常兴奋，但愉快度没那么高，不是愉快度低的清单。我们要求他们每周从我们给他们的清单中做大约一小时的事情。10周后，那些做了兴奋清单活动的夫妻，对关系的满意度有了显著提高。
In fact, the other couples were slightly less so, but not much so. You know, it's also boredoms a problem. You know, we've done lab studies. We had a study where couples came into the lab, and they were told they'd be videotape doing an activity together. And they filled out some questionnaires first. And we did take them, but it didn't matter. What they were doing, in one condition, the expanding condition, we tied their wrists and ankles
事实上，其他夫妻的满意度略有下降，但不多。你知道，无聊也是一个问题。你知道，我们做过实验室研究。我们有一项研究，夫妻来到实验室，被告知他们将被录像，一起做一项活动。他们先填写了一些问卷。我们确实录了，但这并不重要。他们在做什么，在一种情况下，即扩展条件下，我们用魔术贴带子把他们的手腕和脚踝
together with Velcro straps. And they had a big long gym mat, you know, that went very long, two or three of them across a room. They had to push a foam roller across and back without using their fingers or teeth and over a barrier in the middle, a round barrier. And they had to do it within a certain amount of time. And they had three chances to do it, four chances to do it. Sounds like a TV show, you know, like beat the clock. Right. And the control condition, they just each went back separately. And it was pleasant. They didn't mind that. They thought it was sort of funny, but they didn't know about the other condition. And then, and we timed it.
绑在一起。他们有一个很大的长健身垫，你知道，很长，两三个垫子横跨一个房间。他们必须在不使用手指或牙齿的情况下，把一个泡沫轴推过去再推回来，还要越过中间的一个障碍物，一个圆形的障碍物。他们必须在一定时间内完成。他们有三次机会完成，四次机会完成。听起来像个电视节目，你知道，像“打败时钟”（beat the clock）。对。在对照组中，他们只是各自单独走过去。这很愉快。他们不介意。他们觉得这有点好笑，但他们不知道另一种情况。然后，我们计时了。
They had to take watches off to do this and stuff. So we timed it so that they didn't quite make it the first two times, the third time they just made. If it was unbelievable that they had made it the third time, then they made it the fourth time. And the couples who did the exciting activity versus the pleasant, well, we had in one of the, a couple of the studies, we had a questionnaire air afterwards, but in another study, we had them have a conversation afterwards. And again, they didn't know which condition they were in or anything like that. And the conversation was, you know, it was friendly conversation. Suppose you were given a bunch of money to go on a trip, where would you choose to go or to remodel your home, you know. And we had people coding the
他们必须摘下手表来做这个之类的。所以我们计时了，这样他们前两次没能完成，第三次刚好完成。如果他们第三次完成了，那真是不可思议，然后他们第四次完成了。那些做兴奋活动与愉快活动的夫妻，嗯，我们在其中一项研究中，之后有一份问卷，但在另一项研究中，我们让他们之后进行了一次谈话。同样，他们不知道自己处于哪种条件下，或者类似的事情。谈话是，你知道，友好的谈话。假设你得到了一笔钱去旅行，你会选择去哪里，或者装修你的家，你知道。我们让那些不知道受试者处于哪种条件下的编码员对
conversations who didn't know which condition the subjects were in. And those who were in the exciting condition had much more positive interaction. And then there's been studies that by others. I mean, there's been a lot of replication of this. Studies that followed people up four months later, you know, things like that. We did one study where we had a sample that had been, this is from Terry Orbach and group sample, where they have a large sample, national sample. And they followed people for like, what was I think was year nine and 17, something like that we were looking at. And their ratings of how exciting their daily life is with their partner, how bored they were, you know, predicted their satisfaction at year 17, you know, nine years later, whatever it was.
谈话进行编码。那些处于兴奋条件下的夫妻有更多积极的互动。然后还有其他人做的研究。我的意思是，这已经有很多重复研究了。研究在四个月后跟踪了人们，你知道，诸如此类的事情。我们做了一项研究，我们有一个样本，这是来自特里·奥尔巴赫（Terry Orbach）小组的样本，他们有一个大样本，全国性样本。他们跟踪了人们，比如，我想是第9年和第17年，我们观察的是类似这样的时间点。他们对与伴侣的日常生活有多兴奋、有多无聊的评价，预测了他们17年后的满意度，你知道，9年后，无论是什么。
And some of the most recent research has shown that one of the reasons this is working is that it increases your sex life. It makes your sex more lively. So that's one big thing. Another big thing is your sex life. And just physical contact is really important. You don't need to have sex. every day, you know. Once an hour is, you don't need to have sex every day. In fact, once a week for most people is just about the right amount. You know, and it's important that both of you want to have it, you enjoy it, and you have a little variation, what you do a little bit. But that's sort of crucial. But, you know, sometimes, like in the big national sample we did of people who claimed to be intensely in love after, you know, 10, 20 years together. There were a few older couples
最近的一些研究表明，这之所以有效的原因之一是它增加了你的性生活。它让你的性生活更活跃。所以这是一个大因素。另一个大因素是你的性生活。仅仅是身体接触也非常重要。你不需要每天都做爱，你知道。每小时一次，你不需要每天都做爱。事实上，对大多数人来说，每周一次是恰到好处的量。你知道，重要的是你们两个都想做，你们享受它，并且你们做的事情有一点变化。但这某种程度上是至关重要的。但是，你知道，有时，就像我们在全国性大样本中调查的那些声称在在一起10年、20年后依然深爱着对方的人。有几对年长的夫妻
who weren't ever having sex, but they had a lot of physical contact. And in fact, even in a daily basis, aside from the sex, just, you know, holding your partner's hand, hugging them, those sorts of things. To the extent, it's legitimate and feels honest is really important. And there's a lot of research showing that. So, you know, physical contact, sex. And of course, eking time out together, alone from your children or your extended family is kind of important in part to have sex, you know. So it's, but it sounds like you should be putting aside some time for sort of a date night and maybe, maybe go skydiving, you know, do something that's really going to
他们从来不做爱，但他们有很多身体接触。事实上，即使在日常生活中，除了性之外，只是，你知道，握住你伴侣的手，拥抱他们，诸如此类的事情。只要是合法的并且感觉真诚，就非常重要。有很多研究表明这一点。所以，你知道，身体接触、性。当然，从你的孩子或大家庭中挤出时间单独在一起也很重要，部分是为了做爱，你知道。所以，这听起来你应该留出一些时间来过“约会之夜”，也许，也许去跳伞，你知道，做一些真正能
get your blood pumping. You're right. Skydiving is a great example. It's important that you do things that are challenging and interesting, but not more than you can handle. There's this study showing this sort of curvilinear effect that up to the point where you handle the challenge, the more challenge the better. But when it goes beyond that, diminishing returns. Yeah, like my wife, you know, really loves going out in water and really
让你的血液泵动起来的事情。你说得对。跳伞是一个很好的例子。重要的是你要做一些具有挑战性和有趣的事情，但不要超过你能承受的范围。有一项研究显示了这种曲线效应，即在你能处理挑战的范围内，挑战越大越好。但当它超过那个范围时，收益就会递减。是的，就像我妻子，你知道，真的很喜欢去水里，真的很
loves whales. And I love whales too. So she said, why don't we go on a whale watching trip? But I get seasick. And so we took all, we said, well, let's try when I took all these pills and things you put on your wrist and stuff like that. And we went out and I fed the whales, um, leaving over the But she had a great time. Well, yeah, she was supporting me. And the support was good, you know, failing her support. But, you know, we had to stay out there a long time because it was a group, you know, thing. But so it is important to do things.
喜欢鲸鱼。我也喜欢鲸鱼。所以她说，我们为什么不去观鲸呢？但我晕船。所以我们带了所有，我们说，好吧，让我们试试，我吃了所有这些药，还有你戴在手腕上的东西之类的。我们出去了，我喂了鲸鱼，呃，从船边探出头去。但她玩得很开心。嗯，是的，她在支持我。这种支持很好，你知道，感受她的支持。但是，你知道，我们必须在外面待很长时间，因为这是一个团体活动。所以，做这些事情很重要。
They have to be new. As I say, taking a cooking class together or, you know, a dance class, of course, is some physical thing. But it's not the physical. You know, we've done studies when people initially meet. And when they initially meet being physiologically turned on. I don't mean sexually, but just stirred up, does make you more likely to be attracted to a new person. And the novelty of it isn't what matters. But in a long-term relationship, what matters is the novelty and not the amount of physical stirring.
它们必须是新的。正如我所说，一起去上烹饪课，或者，你知道，舞蹈课，当然，这是一种身体活动。但不仅仅是身体上的。你知道，我们做过研究，当人们最初见面时。当他们最初见面时，生理上被唤起。我不是指性方面，只是被搅动起来，确实让你更有可能被一个新的人吸引。新奇感并不是唯一重要的。但在长期关系中，重要的是新奇感，而不是身体搅动的程度。
When you meet a new person, if you've just, you know, exercised and, you know, worked up, you know, for 20 minutes and you're all stirred up. You're more likely, if they're reasonably attractive, you're more likely to think, oh, I know why I'm worked up. I'm attracted to them. But in the long-term relationship, you know, you're used to being worked up from exercising. It doesn't do. It's the novelty that sort of rekindles things. Yeah, that makes sense. And then there's some others that are important.
当你遇到一个新的人时，如果你刚刚，你知道，锻炼了，你知道，运动了20分钟，你整个人都被搅动起来了。你更有可能，如果他们相当有吸引力，你更有可能想，哦，我知道我为什么这么激动。我被他们吸引了。但在长期关系中，你知道，你习惯了从锻炼中被搅动起来。这没用。是新奇感在某种程度上重燃了火花。是的，这说得通。然后还有一些其他重要的因素。
And here's where the 36 questions come in. Deep friendships with other couples matter a lot. Now, the 36 questions for the few people who aren't familiar with it is a procedure that takes about 45 minutes that we design. so we could create closeness in the laboratory. The problem is that if you want to study the effects of closeness scientifically, you want to be able to randomly assign people to be close or not. If you just take people who are close versus not, they have different histories, they chose each other.
这就是那36个问题发挥作用的地方。与其他夫妻的深厚友谊非常重要。现在，对于少数不熟悉它的人来说，这36个问题是我们设计的一个过程，大约需要45分钟。这样我们就可以在实验室中创造亲密感。问题在于，如果你想科学地研究亲密感的影响，你需要能够随机分配人们是否亲密。如果你只是找那些亲密与不亲密的人，他们有不同的历史，他们选择了彼此。
So we wanted to be able to create a procedure, which in 45 minutes could do that. And so we developed that procedure. And that was not intended to make people fall in love, was to make people close. In fact, most of the people in our studies were heterosexual people paired with same-sex others. But it created closeness, created closeness. And that was the idea. Now, of course, if everything else is in place and closeness can add to the chance of falling in
所以我们想要能够创造一个过程，在45分钟内就能做到这一点。所以我们开发了那个过程。那并不是为了让人坠入爱河，而是为了让人亲密。事实上，我们研究中的大多数人是异性恋者与同性恋者配对。但它创造了亲密感，创造了亲密感。这就是那个想法。现在，当然，如果其他一切都到位，亲密感可以增加最初坠入爱河的机会，但那不是目标。现在，它有什么作用？嗯，如果你和正在进行的关系中的伴侣一起做，它确实，你知道，如果你在长期关系中，它确实让你感觉和伴侣更亲密。但它并不能特别增加爱。但有所有的研究表明，如果夫妻与另一对夫妻有深厚的友谊，他们更有可能相爱并对他们的关系感到快乐。我们不知道是哪一个导致了哪一个。
love initially, but that wasn't the goal. Now, what does it do? Well, if you do it with an ongoing partner, it does, you know, it does make you feel closer to your partner if you're in a long-term relationship. But it doesn't particularly increase love. But there's all this research showing that if couples have a close friendship with another couple, they're more likely to be in love and happy in their relationship. We don't know which is causing which.
最初的研究是由里奇·斯拉彻（Rich Slatcher）完成的。事实上，这是他的博士论文。后来，我和他合作了一系列研究。还有基思·威尔克（Keith Welker），他的另一位前学生。我们发现，当一对夫妻自己做这件事时，正如我所说，他们变得更亲密，但这并不一定会增加他们的爱。但当两对夫妻一起做，作为四人组，四个人中的每一个人都回答这36个问题中的每一个。它不仅使他们彼此之间以及与另一对夫妻之间更亲密，
The initial study was done by Rich Slatcher. This was his dissertation, in fact. And then later, I collaborated with him on a bunch of studies. And Keith Welker, another former student of his. And what we found was that when a couple does it by themselves, as I say, they get closer, but it doesn't necessarily increase their love. But when two couples do it together is a four-sum, each of the four answers each of the 36 questions. It not only makes them closer to each other and to the other couple,
而且它增加了夫妻内部的激情之爱。它们真的是很棒的问题。我的意思是，你能随便抛出几个吗？因为我知道你从某种，你知道，某种熟悉程度开始，然后深入。对。这个想法来自调查研究，显示当人们形成友谊时——这是我们当时的主要关注点——他们通过最初不，你知道，某种交换，然后逐渐透露越来越多。你知道，如果有人透露得太多太快，
but it increases their passionate love within the couple. And they're really great questions. I mean, can you just toss a couple out there? Because I know you start at a certain level of, you know, sort of familiar, and then you go deep. Right. The idea of this came from survey research showing that when people form French, which is our main focus at the time, they do so by initially not being, you know, sort of exchanging and then gradually revealing more and more. You know, if someone reveals too much too fast,
这有点吓人，会让你反感，你知道。所以我们设置了一组问题，最初你回答问题，你知道，如果你能，你知道，和历史上任何人共进晚餐，你会想和谁共进晚餐，诸如此类的事情。然后到最后，你知道，我们最初是。和大学生一起做这个。如果你的母亲去世了，你会感觉如何？你知道，我的意思是，它，你知道，它就这样推进。我们还加入了其他两三个重要的问题。过了一会儿，我们问，你有没有注意到你和对方有什么共同点。我们从来不说，如果你注意到你有什么共同点。
it sort of is a little scary, it puts you off and, you know. So we set up a set of questions where initially you answer questions, you know, if you could, you know, go out with to dinner with anyone in history, who would you want to go out to dinner with and things like that. And then towards the end, you know, we initially were. doing this with college-age students. How would you feel if your mother died? You know, I mean, it's, you know, it's so it moves along. And we also threw in two or three other questions that mattered. After a little while, we asked, have you noticed anything you have in common with the other person. And we never say, if you notice anything, you don't have in common.
同样，有共同点并不那么重要，但认为你们有共同点很重要。然后稍后，我们有一些项目说，列出一些你喜欢的关于对方的事情。事实证明，这是对某人感到亲密的一个巨大因素。事实上，这是最初坠入爱河的一个巨大因素，就是认为对方喜欢你。现在，人们认为36个问题，那要花多长时间？有三组12个问题。我们说，不要急。我们不指望你们全部完成。我们有12个问题的原因是有些人进展很快。我们不想让他们用完。但大多数人会完成六七个。你和另一对夫妻一起做这个。你可以，
Again, being in common isn't that important, but thinking you're in common. And then also a little later, we have some items that say, name some things you like about. You've noticed you like about the other person. Turns out that's a huge factor in feeling close to someone. And in fact, it's a huge factor initially falling in love is thinking the other person likes you. Now, people think 36 questions, how long is that going to take? There's three sets of 12 questions. And we say, don't rush it. We don't expect you to get through all of them. And the reason we have 12 questions is some people move quickly. We don't want them to run out. But most people will get through six or seven. And you do this with another couple. You've got to,
想做多久就做多久，但最好不要花太长时间。你知道，你会对它感到厌烦，但它真的很有价值。事实上，我和我妻子和我们认识的夫妻做过一两次，通过Zoom。这是你可以通过Zoom和世界另一端的另一对夫妻一起做的事情，比如我们在瑞典的一些朋友，你知道。所以这是一个相当强大的东西。关于这36个问题，我应该提醒人们的一件事是，如果他们最初用它们来和朋友变得更亲密，或者和，你知道，他们正在约会的人，你不能一次又一次地使用同一套问题，因为你，你知道答案。
can do it as long as you want, but it's better not to take too long. You know, you'll get bored with it, but it's really valuable. In fact, my wife and I have done this once or twice with couples, we know a little bit by Zoom. It's something you can do over the, you know, by Zoom with another couple who's on the other side of the world, like some friends we have in Sweden, you know. So it's a pretty powerful thing. One thing I should remind people about the 36 questions, if they're using them either initially to get closer with a friend or with, you know, someone they're dating, is you can't use the same set of questions again and again and again because you get, you know the answers.
对。嗯，你知道，这一集是为了纪念情人节。我只是在想，你知道，很多人有点轻视“霍尔马克节日”（hallmark holiday，指商业化节日）在长期关系中的重要性。你认为留出一天来承认和庆祝浪漫爱情有助于关系，还是这只会导致未满足的期望和，你知道，价格过高的餐厅餐点？我的意思是，我不知道关于这个的任何研究，但我认为把你的注意力放在
Right. Well, you know, this episode is being time to Mark Valentine's Day. And I'm just wondering, you know, a lot of people kind of poo-poo the importance of a hallmark holiday in a long-term relationship. Do you think that a day set aside to recognize? and celebrate romantic love helps relationships, or is it something that just leads to unmet expectations and, you know, an overpriced restaurant meal? I mean, I don't know of any research on this, but I think putting your attention on the
对。嗯，你知道，这一集是为了配合情人节而制作的。我只是在想，你知道，很多人对长期关系中这种商业节日的重要性嗤之以鼻。你认为专门留出一天来认可和庆祝浪漫爱情对关系有帮助吗？还是说这只会导致期望落空，以及，你知道，一顿价格过高的餐厅晚餐？我的意思是，我不知道这方面有什么研究，但我认为把注意力放在
relationship is a good thing. There's a couple more things you can do to sparkle it up, and one of them is to express gratitude and to think about what you're grateful for in your relationship. And a holiday is a good day to do that. Why? What am I great? for that my partner has given me. And of course, it's also important on a day-to-day basis when something happens. You know, again, you want to be honest about it. You don't want to say thank you for something. It doesn't matter. And one thing that's interesting from some of the recent research, it especially matters in a long-term relationship when you're saying you appreciate they did that thing to not only let them know how hard you thought they worked to make it happen, but how much it
关系是一件好事。你可以做更多的事情来让它焕发光彩，其中之一就是表达感激之情，并思考你在关系中感激什么。节日是一个做这件事的好日子。为什么？我因为伴侣给予我的一切而感到感激吗？当然，在日常生活中，当事情发生时，表达感激也很重要。你知道，同样，你要真诚地表达。你不想为了某件无关紧要的事情而说谢谢。最近的一些研究中有一个有趣的发现，在长期关系中，当你表达对伴侣所做之事的感激时，不仅要让他们知道你认为他们为实现这件事付出了多少努力，还要让他们知道这对你意味着什么，你从他们的付出中获得了多少。所以，表达感激和感受感激真的很重要。
meant to you, how much you got from they're doing it. So expressing gratitude and feeling gratitude is really important. And it also reminds me, there's one other thing I didn't get to. Some wonderful work on celebrating your partner's successes. You know, if your partner has something good happen, you know, don't just say, oh, that's nice, you know, let them know. Really let them know. It turns out that matters more than supporting them when things go badly. My wife, does this research on the highly sensitive person, and we collaborate, which is one of the exciting things we do together. No sounds.
这也让我想起了一件事，我还没来得及说。关于庆祝伴侣成功的一些精彩研究。你知道，如果你的伴侣发生了什么好事，不要只是说“哦，那很好”，要让他们知道。真的要让他们知道。事实证明，这比在他们遇到困难时支持他们更重要。我的妻子正在研究高敏感人群，我们进行合作，这是我们一起做的令人兴奋的事情之一。没有声音。
And we've also collaborated on the relationship research. But she submitted a little while back, she submitted a paper, review paper, to a very top journal, psychology journal on the state of the research on highly sensitive people. And it was a very top journal. We thought the chances of it being accepted were not that high. I was a co-author, but it was her work. I was home when the email came in saying the editor loved it, the reviewers loved it. And so I made a poster of that and put it on the wall for when she came home.
我们也曾在关系研究上进行过合作。前段时间，她向一家非常顶尖的心理学期刊提交了一篇关于高敏感人群研究现状的综述论文。那是一家非常顶尖的期刊。我们认为它被录用的几率并不高。我是合著者，但那是她的工作。当收到编辑说很喜欢这篇论文、审稿人也很喜欢的邮件时，我正在家里。所以我做了一张海报贴在墙上，等她回家时给她看。
We had a great night. But celebrating your partner's success is also matters. And I suppose you could make a point of that to some extent. Like, hey, we're still together. That's a kind of success. So some of the relationship stressors that we've talked about, boredom and, and, you know, you know, just tension have been really, really abundant in our lives these last two years. And it may be a little soon to be talking about what we know about what the pandemic is doing
我们度过了一个美好的夜晚。但庆祝伴侣的成功也很重要。我想你可以在某种程度上强调这一点。比如，“嘿，我们还在一起。”这是一种成功。所以，我们谈到的一些关系压力源，比如无聊和紧张，在过去两年里在我们的生活中非常非常多。现在谈论我们对疫情对人们关系的影响的了解可能还为时过早。
to people's relationships. But I'm just wondering, have you thought about this? Are you doing any research in this area? What are you seeing? Well, I haven't myself done any research in this area. Several of my collaborators, colleagues have. Rich Slatcher, who actually was on one of these podcasts. It's a lot of work in that.
但我只是想知道，你考虑过这个问题吗？你在这个领域做研究吗？你看到了什么？嗯，我自己还没有在这个领域做过研究。我的几位合作者、同事做过。Rich Slatcher，他实际上参加过这些播客中的一期。他在那方面做了很多工作。
Rhonda Belsarini, a former graduate student of mine, has done a lot of work in this area. But they're still just starting to get their results, and I haven't been following it as closely as I might. So I can't really comment on that. But, you know, I mean, I think the one or two things that follow from my research is that, again, even though you can't do the usual things, or even the usual novel things, look for things you can do.
我以前的一位研究生Rhonda Belsarini在这个领域做了很多工作。但他们才刚刚开始得到结果，我并没有像我可能应该做的那样密切关注。所以我不能对此发表评论。但是，我的意思是，我认为从我的研究中得出的那一两点是，即使你不能做通常的事情，甚至不能做通常的新鲜事，也要寻找你能做的事情。
Like I mentioned doing the 36 questions with another couple on the other side of the world by Zoom. You can take a dancing class by Zoom, you know, or, you know, things you can do. You know, sit together and cook some food you'd never done together if you can, if that's interesting to you, you know. And also, you do need some time for yourself. And it's important that people, if they're just alone as a couple, also have a little time alone. so that they're not feeling overburdened. Are there signs that the relationship can't really be salvaged? I mean, sometimes, you know, you reach a rocky point, but even your, the research that you have done
就像我提到的，通过Zoom与地球另一端的另一对夫妇一起做那36个问题。你可以通过Zoom上舞蹈课，或者做一些你能做的事情。你知道，坐在一起做一些你们从未一起做过的食物，如果这对你们来说很有趣的话。而且，你也确实需要一些属于自己的时间。如果他们只是作为一对夫妇单独相处，那么拥有一点独处时间也很重要，这样他们就不会感到负担过重。有没有迹象表明这段关系真的无法挽救？我的意思是，有时你会到达一个艰难的时刻，但即使是你所做的研究
and the suggestions that you make to bring people together, are there some relationships where it really just doesn't matter? I don't know. It's tough. I mean, obviously, if you're being physically abused by someone, a partner, you know, in those kind of cases, or if you've got a partner who's an alcoholic and can't stop and something like that, that can be tough. Short of that, it seems like if people pull these things, you know, can pull these things
以及你提出的让人们走到一起的建议，是否有些关系真的无所谓了？我不知道。这很难。我的意思是，显然，如果你受到伴侣的身体虐待，你知道，在那种情况下，或者如果你的伴侣是酗酒者且无法停止，诸如此类的事情，那可能会很艰难。除此之外，如果人们能把这些事情
together to some extent, they can make almost any relationship work. So if you're really sincere in your effort, I mean, you have to take it seriously and try to follow the instructions. I mean, I've read a fair amount of John Gottman, for example, and he does have a lot of things that he recommends that couples do together and they, at least as far as his work goes, he says they work. Yeah, well, you need both of the members of the couple to be willing to do something. And of course, as I say, sometimes it's just yourself, sometimes just getting your own therapy
在一定程度上处理好，他们几乎可以让任何关系维持下去。所以如果你真的真诚地努力，我的意思是，你必须认真对待并尝试遵循建议。我的意思是，我读过不少John Gottman的书，例如，他确实推荐了很多情侣可以一起做的事情，而且至少就他的工作而言，他说这些方法有效。是的，你需要情侣双方都愿意做些事情。当然，正如我所说，有时只是你自己，有时只是接受你自己的治疗
or doing something to make yourself better off, will make the relationship better and also give you more freedom to do things to make the relationship better. So you've been studying relationships now for, I don't know, 50 years, right? I mean, it's a long time that you've been working in this area. What are the big questions that you still want to answer? We still, you know, we know that these things I went through, each of them predicts more love, more satisfaction. But we don't know for sure, you know, we know a little bit from the survey,
或者做些事情让自己变得更好，会让关系变得更好，也会给你更多的自由去做些事情来改善关系。所以你研究关系已经，我不知道，50年了，对吧？我的意思是，你在这一领域工作了很长时间。你仍然想回答的重大问题是什么？我们仍然，你知道，我们知道我经历过的这些事情，每一项都预示着更多的爱，更多的满足感。但我们并不确定，你知道，我们从调查中了解了一点，
what things really make the few couples that are at the very top get there. And so I'm now doing some research with Terry Orbach and Rosie Shrout, who has this great data set. And also we're trying to gather some other data set. People who've done longitudinal research. And we're trying to see what from early on predicts which couples are not only happy, which is what most of it's been done, but which are super happy, which are, you know, very intensely in love.
到底是什么让处于顶端的少数情侣做到了这一点。所以我现在正在和Terry Orbach以及Rosie Shrout一起做一些研究，她有这个很棒的数据集。我们也在尝试收集其他数据集。那些做过纵向研究的人。我们试图看看早期的情况中，哪些因素预示着哪些情侣不仅幸福（这是大多数研究已经完成的部分），而且是超级幸福，也就是非常深爱对方。
And so we're trying to sort out those data. So it's not like we're not collecting new data. We're trying to sort that out and try to get a strong handle on it. You know, we presume it's a lot of these factors. but we don't know for sure. I mean, we're pretty sure, but it may be just particular combinations that really make it happen or something we haven't looked at. Well, I will look forward to seeing that.
所以我们正在尝试整理这些数据。所以并不是我们没有收集新数据。我们正在尝试整理这些数据，并试图很好地掌握它。你知道，我们推测这是许多因素共同作用的结果。但我们并不确定。我的意思是，我们很确定，但这可能只是特定的组合才真正促成了这一点，或者是我们还没有观察到的东西。好吧，我很期待看到结果。
I appreciate you taking the time to talk to us today. Dr. Aaron, thank you so much. Thank you for inviting me. It's a pleasure to be able to share so much of what our field knows. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. www. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, Spotify, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you're listening on Apple and you like what you hear, please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology
感谢您今天抽出时间与我们交谈。Aaron博士，非常感谢。谢谢您的邀请。很高兴能分享我们领域所了解的这么多知识。您可以在我们的网站www.speakingofpsychology.org或Apple、Stitcher、Spotify或您获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集。如果您在Apple上收听并且喜欢您所听到的内容，请给我们留下评论。如果您对未来的播客有意见或想法，您可以发送电子邮件至speaking of psychology
at APA.org. That's Speaking of Psychology, all one word, at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condyenne. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
at APA.org。即Speaking of Psychology，全部连在一起，at APA.org。《心理学谈话》由Lee Weinerman制作。我们的声音编辑是Chris Condyenne。感谢您的收听。我是美国心理学会的Kim Mills。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。